[Musique]
on a trop considéré et quand je dis ça
quand je dis on s'est beaucoup de
l'étang
que c'était à l'enfant de suivre notre
organisation administrative est en
réalité c'est ça qui provoque qui crée
un certain nombre d'autres s'amusent
rupture que l'on connaît dans l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et qui sont souvent
d'une fait de notre mauvaise
coordination mauvaise coopération
entre état et département dans les
parcours d'enfant et puis parfois entre
les services de l'état et même
la rs éducation nationale la justice
qu'il joue un rôle important même si le
système initialement était censé être
système plus administratif que
judiciaire dans les faits il est c'est
judicieux harris
donc voilà c'est le discours que j'ai
que j'ai que j'ai tenu et ce projet de
loi je pense at elle un peu à travailler
sai l'état doit être aussi au rendez
vous de ses propres compétences et donc
on a lancé cette grande concertation sur
la réforme de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
il y avait sept ministères représentés
dans la salle et c'était une première je
pense et c'était une nécessité puisque
un enjeu aussi côté voilà j'essaie
d'aller aller à l'essentiel ce que je
commence à 10 graissé mais vous dire
donc que cette concertation lancée avec
les départements pendant trois quatre
mois a conduit à une stratégie que je
n'estime donc pas être la mienne propre
mais être celle que nous avons co
construite ensemble une stratégie de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
donc pas que de protection mais de
prévention et protection chance car les
deux sont liés cette stratégie elle
s'articule autour de deux choses d'une
part un volet de contractualisation avec
les départements sur le modèle du plat
stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
nous avons contractualisé avec 30
départements la première année en 2020
40 cette année 2021 et j'ai annoncé au
président françois sauvadet en côte d'or
la semaine dernière que nous étendions
comme nous l'avions promis aux trente
derniers départements pour l'année 2020
end
pourquoi je vous parle de cette
contractualisation d'une barbe on veut
dire nous avions défini quatre grands
objectifs avec les départements
proposer une série de d'action très
concrètes à mettre en place très
opérationnelle très concrète des
créations de places pour les fratries
par exemple des dispositifs pour mieux
prendre en considération la parole de
l'enfant dans les territoires mieux
réinvestir sap émis par exemple pour le
volet prévention
voilà avec deux obligations pour les
départements
réinvestir dans leur permis de nous
proposer des dispositifs pour les
enfants en situation de handicap de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance ils sont 20%
nous les prenons mal en charge
collectivement on doit trouver de
nouvelles solutions
pour anticiper quelques questions et
remarques qui seront les vôtres mais
nous y reviendrons sachez que via cette
contractualisation de l'état va
réinvestir lui même dans les pmi 100
millions d'euros sur trois ans 100
millions d'euros c'est ce que le rapport
de la députée michel perron avait
identifié comme la perte
constatée des pmi ces dix dernières
années en trois ans l'état réinvesti les
100 millions d'euros qui ont été perdus
globalement sur les trois ans à travers
la contractualisation l'état réinvestira
investira 600 millions d'euros dans la
protection de l'enfance donc vous vous
me direz je pense je ne vais pas ce que
ça a été dit déjà en séance à d'autres
lors d'autres débats qu'un certain
nombre de dispositifs peut-être génère
des coûts pour les collectivités locales
et je vous répondrai
je dévoile un peu déjà à ma réponse que
il est vrai mais que à travers la
contractualisation nous avons déjà
compenser les coûts supplémentaires qui
pouvait avoir lieu question des fratries
par exemple puisque vous avez vu dans le
projet de loi il ya un principe
d'interdiction de séparation des
fratries ça peut s'amener cécité région
crée des places on comprend bien que
quand il ya 2-3 parfois quatre cinq six
sept enfants a placé ça nécessite
d'avoir les dispositifs qui les
accueillent et donc ça nécessite parfois
de créer des places supplémentaires et
bien dans le cadre de la
contractualisation
nous avons prévu de financer 600 places
la création de 600 places de fratrie à
travers la contractualisation
le deuxième grand volet de cette
stratégie de prévention économique
protection de l'enfance à côté de ce
volet contractualisation je viens
d'évoquer c'est essayer de se créer un
cadre parce que national d'exercices
communs de cette compétence
évidemment ça reste une compétence
départementale pour autant on peut
comprendre je pensais à admettre tous
les uns et les autres que sur un certain
nombre d'aspects il est important
d'avoir une approche
nationale au nom de
certaine équité notamment territoriales
un exemple de cette démarche qui est
encore construction qui n'étant rien
imposé par l'état se fait ensemble
c
par exemple
l'élaboration par la haute autorité de
santé
selon ses méthodes qui ont beaucoup
associé les départements il ya plus de
soixante départements je crois qu'ils
ont participé à ce travail de deux ans
d'une d'un référentiel d'évaluation des
situations de danger
car on comprend aisément qu'il n'y a
aucune raison objective aucun grands
principes constitutionnels qui peut
justifier qu'un enfant ne soient pas
considérés en danger de la même façon
qu'il soit à lille ou à marseille
et que les griffes utilisent les
travailleurs sociaux les grippes
l'éducation nationale ne soit pas la
même pour évaluer la situation d'un
enfant et donc la haute autorité de
santé a élaboré ces référentiels
d'évaluation le deuxième exemple nous en
parlerons je pense la question des
assistants familiaux
vous avez vu ça fait l'objet de la
concertation est depuis en sortie de
concertation il ya eu huit mois de
négociation collective pas au sens du
droit du travail mais nous en tant
qu'etat on a mis autour de la table on a
joué les facilitateurs avec les
départements l'adf les employeurs privés
les associations et les syndicats
d'assistante familiale pour essayer sur
la saslong deux choses
la formation la rémunération
la question complexe de la suspension
des agréments en cas de suspicion de
maltraitance voilà pour essayer au
niveau national de secret des règles
communes vous en retrouver certaines
dans la loi et d'autres qui sont à côté
de la loi parce que pas d'ordre
législatif tout simplement échange je
vous ferai un point d'avancement
l'addition
voilà donc l ce nombre de choses qui
sont d'ordre national et puis donc et
parmi celles ci un centre qui sont
d'ordre législatives et c'est donc ce
que vous retrouvez dans ce texte
est donc ce texte n'est que cela c'est à
la fois beaucoup parce que je pense que
les mesures qui sont comprises sont
importantes
sont sur le
font progresser le système on bénéfice
de la protection des enfants étant
entendu je dis ça devant madame la
ministre je m'inscris totalement
dans la lignée des lois de 2007 je dis
pas à l'époque et de laurence rossignol
en 2016 je ne suis pas arriver en disant
tout va mal on ré et attise
où tout va mal on change totalement de
système
je pense que nous avons un système qui
parfois dysfonctionne pour des
comportements individuels parfois parce
que je l' ai dit tout à l'heure nos
propres institutions nos propres
carences de coordination de coopération
génère des ruptures et des difficultés
mais nous avons un système aussi qui
protège et nous avons des travailleurs
engagés en faveur des enfants et donc je
m'inscris
très aisément
dans la lignée de ses deux grands textes
de protection de l'enfance dans notre
pays en pensant modestement que ça
permet d'aller encore un creux un cran
un cran plus loin très brièvement je
vais regarder l'heure
les quelques grands principes
de ce texte
le point grands principes c'est
améliorer la sécurité des enfants
conférences de consensus docteur martin
blaché initiée par laurence rossignol le
méta besoin la sécurité de l'enfant
qu'elle soit effective matériel ou
physiques et donc là un certain nombre
de dispositions qui visent à améliorer
la sécurité des enfants la sécurité
physique d'une barre
avec le renforcement des contrôles des
antécédents judiciaires
des professionnels quel que soit leur
statut qui sont au contact des enfants
dans le système de la protection de
l'enfance avec la création de
référents dans les départements de
référence sur les violences vers
lesquels les enfants pourraient pourront
se tourner si il mais il souffre de
violence dans le cadre de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance avec l'obligation pour les
établissements d'adopter des plans de
lutte contre la maltraitance
dans leur schéma
avec une attention particulière portée
aux enfants en situation de handicap
dont il sait qu'ils sont encore plus
vulnérables que les autres les autres
enfants
avec la création d'une base nationale
frise assistants familiaux on
connaissait le sujet nos kiné qui n'est
pas courant et pas non plus dans l'axé
chose mais le nomadisme administrative
d'assistants familiaux dont l'agrément
avait été suspendue retirer ce sont des
choses qui ont pu exister et qui ne sont
pas admissibles donc base nationale ou
encore la question
création de première norme sociale est
le seul endroit où il n'y a aucune norme
sur les taux d'encadrement sur la
formation des professionnels ce n'est
pas dans la loi c'est un sujet
importante qui a des impacts qui peut
avoir des impacts évidemment sur les
aspirations sur les départements c'est
d'ordre réglementaire conseil d'état
nous l'a rappelé c'est dans le texte
initial c'est travailler à côté en ce
moment avec les services avec l'adf avec
les départements et avec les
associations
mais bon en avant sur quelques normes
pour un peu mieux encadrer les choses et
en fin d'année sujet sur la sécurité
physique la question des hôtels et donc
nous y reviendrons je pense principe
d'interdiction des enfants à l'hôtel
dans la lignée d'un rapport que j'avais
commandé à l'igas sur ce sujet ça
concernait à l'époque sept à dix mille
enfants à 95% des mineurs non
accompagnés
j'ai eu l'appel dont nous sortant la
crise sanitaire et l'impact a pu avoir
sur certaines migration je pense que ce
niveau a baissé il reste néanmoins
beaucoup d'enfants dans les hôtels il ya
des départements dans lesquels il n'y a
pas d'enfant à l'hôtel et donc c'est
possible alors que il ya alors qu'il ya
une population de mineurs
non-accompagnés
sûr c'est sur ces territoires voilà
principe d'interdiction avec un principe
de dérogation on y reviendra je m'étends
pas j'imagine qu'il ya des questions sur
le sur le sur le sujet deuxième aspect
brièvement c'est la sécurité affective
avec un article qui a été peu commenté
mais qui je pense peut avoir un levier
de transformation
qui est l'article 1er sur l'obligation
pour les travailleurs sociaux et pour
les juges
d'interroger la possibilité de confier
un enfant à un tir digne de confiance
avant qu'ils soient placés on a un
système en france qui est très
institutionnelle moi j'ai toujours
dit qu'il y avait trois cercles de
protection autour de l'enfant le premier
c'est la famille évidemment quand même
enfin il faut le rappeler même si
parfois elle et elle est allée violente
mais elle est quand même dans la grande
majorité des cas protectrice fort
heureusement le deuxième cercle c'est
justement la famille élargie l'entourage
s'étire digne de confiance et puis le
troisième cercle quand les deux premiers
sont défaillants ou non mobilisables
c'est le système institutionnel le
cercle national mais dans un pays comme
l'allemagne y en avoir beaucoup parlé
notamment avec frédéric bierry qu'ils
prisent dans la commission des affaires
sociales l'adf en allemagne le système
est beaucoup moins institutionnel que ça
il ya beaucoup plus d'enfants qui sont
chez des tiers digne de confiance alors
c'est l'intérêt ce père de l'enfant qui
prime évidemment être retient digne de
confiance même quand on est grands
parents par exemple est élevé sont
petite enfance pas la même chose que le
voir le week-end évidemment donc il faut
être accompagné la accompagnant cela les
députés ont rajouté une disposition à
cet égard qui est pertinente et puis il
faut il faut que la parole de l'enfant
bien évidemment sur a aussi pris en
considération
c'est une évidence n'est pas toujours le
cas ça a été rajoutée de mémoire parlée
par les députés
donc tir digne de confiance interdiction
de séparation des fratries je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure
tout ça on peut se dire c'est déjà le
cas mais en fait c'est un fait c'est pas
vrai c'est que les travailleurs sociaux
par exemple ce serait indigne de
confiance où les jeunes ne s'en empare
pas ne font pas le ce n'est pas
systématique du tout et c'est vrai et là
peut-être choquer les parlementaires que
vous êtes mais c'est de lancer un
parlementaire aussi qui le dit c'est
vrai que la loi
ne fait pas tout ne résout pas tout et
ce n'est pas la prétention de ce texte
non plus et j'ai bien conscience vous le
savez que il ya la loi et puis il ya
aussi la pratique professionnelle et
aussi la formation qu'ont reçues les
différentes personnes qui interviennent
les 20 ans de pratique l on tue qu'ils
et elles ont pu exercer et que donc vous
ces choses là oui met un peu de temps a
changé mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'il
ne faut pas l'affirmer le rendre
systématique obligatoire et ça dans un
texte de loi saulcy aussi sa force voilà
les filles dernier chose ça s'est jetée
affective tout ce qui a trait aux actes
usuels et non usuelle vous connaissez la
problématique je pense voilà il ya 100
ans de l'enfant
qui ne peuvent pas par exemple exemple
parmi d'autres partis en classe verte
avec leurs copains de classe parce que
les parents ne sont pas d'accord et donc
la possibilité sans porter atteinte à
l'autorité parentale et aux familles
c'est toujours un équilibre là qu'il
faut il faut essayer de préserver mais
toujours avec l'intérêt de l'enfant
quand même en
principe directeur de notre action mais
permettre au juge au moment de
l'audience de liste et toute une série
d'actes que les travailleurs se saoulent
afem l'assistante familiale pourront
prendre sans avoir à chaque fois repassé
devant le juge et tout ça est revue tous
les ans ou tous les deux ans aux
fonctions et donc est donc peut être
modifié voilà troisième aspect les
assistants familiaux je pense que l'art
à des questions là-dessus mais dont vous
avez vu qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions qui sont issus des
négociations qu'on a mené des
discussions qu'ont amené avec eux
pendant huit mois dans le texte et puis
un certain nombre qui ne sont pas le
dantec ce parce que d'ordre
réglementaire pour n'est en train de
continuer à travailler on revoit
l'ingénierie des je vous les livre comme
ça quand même causé une vision complète
on revoit l'ingénierie du diplôme passé
niveau 5a niveau 4 on est en train de
revoir les villes la formation initié le
contenu de la formation initiale
notamment sur la question de la prison
de la connaissance et la prise en
considération des enfants à besoins
spécifiques qui sont souvent chez les
assistantes familiales
sympa et puis aussi la meilleure
rémunération
des enfants fin des cours pour l'accueil
d'un enfant situation de handicap on est
en train d'essayer de valoriser et puis
dans la loi vous avez smic dès le
premier enfant vous avez l'histoire de
la suspension pendant les 4 mois et un
maintien des garanties de salage vous
avez la possibilité d'exercer au delà de
la retraite l'aja recettes donc ce n'est
pas une réforme de la retraite des
retraites caché avec une mesure d'âge
jeune glisser là c'est tout simplement
vous le savez il ya des enfants qui sont
parfois inattendus chez les médecins de
famille elle depuis parfois trois quatre
mois depuis à pouponnière et puis à 14
ans parce que la sainte famille al par
la retraite et moi on les change de
famille quoi bon on va serrer une fois
encore ça n'arrive pas tous les jours
mais ça arrive et ce type de rupture en
fait sont pas admissibles donc on perd
mais vous êtes sentinelle de continuer
tout ça est encadré il ya une visite
médicale s'est année après année voilà
tout ça est fait est fait je pense dans
l'est dans l'est dans les cannes donc
tout un volet se hissant familiaux tout
un volet sur alors l'autonomie des
jeunes
bon c'est un sujet qui mériterait je m'y
attèle un peu évidemment mais vous dire
d'une part car indépendamment de la loi
on a pris un certain nombre de
dispositions d'ores et déjà pour
permettre notamment aux enfants trop peu
nombreux 6 % qui font des études
supérieures d'accéder automatiquement au
niveau 7 des bourses parce qu'il sort de
l'assuré enfants dont 680 euros par mois
automatiquement logement étudiant
et par ailleurs dans la loi j'ai donc
introduit un amendement qui en gros 6
pour objectif qui nous fixe
collectivement pour objectif qu'il n'y
ait pas un seul jeune qui sort de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance sans solution est
donc ça veut dire notamment pour ceux
qui sont dans des filières en fin de
parcours une trajectoire d'insertion
professionnelle c'est un accès
automatique à la garantie jeunes
et avec comme vrai donc l'état prend ses
responsabilités et havrais avec articulé
avec des dispositifs contrat jeune
majeur pour les jeunes qui ne répondrait
pas aux pour lesquels la garantie je ne
serai pas le dispositif un dispositif
pertinent et donc dans ce cas là ça doit
être le département qui doit en
subsidiarité en quelque sorte assumer
ses responsabilités pour faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas un seul jeunes qui
sortent sans solution à côté ça il ya
tout un sujet passionnant compliqué mais
qu'on commence à mettre sur le sujet
qu'est la question du droit à l'erreur
et du droit au retour ou retour quand on
est jeune on a le droit de se tromper
soi l'aide sociale à l'enfance ou pas et
parfois ça se passe pas forcément comme
on le souhaite ou comment on pensait et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
introduit je crois que ça a été
renforcée par les députés un entretien à
j + 6 mois de la sortie du dispositif
pour ne pas couper complètement tous les
ponts et à tout moment à la demande du
jeune jusqu'au 21 jusqu'à ses 21 ans
voilà comme ça le lien n'est pas et puis
il ya un sujet là dessus mais j'y
viendrai à la fin où il ya peut-être
encore des choses à faire de votre côté
je vous soumettrai une réflexion que
jamais qui n'est pas abouti enfin j'ai
pas trouvé la solution voilà et puis
dernier sujet
la question de la gouvernance
et je le cite juste parce que je vais y
revenir bon voilà quelques grands
principes objectifs
élément de ceux de ce projet doit pour
terminer je veux conclure se repose sur
deux trois points un bon vous dire je l'
ai déjà dit mais que effectivement vous
me direz probablement qu'à certaines de
ces solutions ont un coût pour les
finances locales qu'elles doivent être
compensés vous dire donc via la
contractualisation en quelque sorte
elles le sont déjà pour une partie
d'entre elles souligné aussi d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un peu technique mais
j'ai même pas à le préciser qu'il ya une
disposition de la loi qui permet de le
remboursement d'un certain nombre
d'actes des pmi car dans beaucoup de
territoires en réalité c'est la pmi qui
se substitue à la médecine scolaire
notamment pour les bilans en maternelle
et voilà et et dans certains territoires
sais je sais pas si ses côtés monferran
saves bénéficier de remboursements et
dans la plupart ce n'est pas le cas or
donc j'ai été alerté sur deux par balles
deux départements là dessus et or je
trouve ça normal enfin c'est juste ça me
semble logique et du bon sens et donc à
une disposition de la loi qui permet le
remboursement des actes faits par les
pmi dans ce cadre là et c'est out ça
représente du je crois qu'on avait
estimé à environ 20 à 25 millions
d'euros
premier point le deuxième point vous
dire je pense enfin c'est pas que je
pense c'est que je suis sûr parce que
j'ai fait en sorte mais vous aurez
peut-être plus d'idées encore que moi
que il ya encore un nombre d'incidents
de sujets ouverts et c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que je vous le que je vous
soumets ce père je partage ce texte avec
vous soit parce qu'on n'a pas été au
bout soit parce que il
ils concernent vraiment encore plus
directement que le reste les
départements et que en tant que
assemblée représentants des
collectivités locales il me semble est
parti fin plus légitime ou pertinent que
les débats aient lieu ici est entendu
par ailleurs que lorsque l'assemblée a
débattu de ce texte les élections
départementales jeunes et d'avoir lieu
mais et le bureau ou presque est en tout
cas le bureau de l'adf association donne
n'était pas encore constitué donc voilà
me semble aussi que c'était important ça
je pense notamment à la question de la
gouvernance territoriale
justement le texte portent leurs efforts
de la gouvernance nationale
avec la création quand même je pense
qu'il faut renforcer le pilotage de
cette politique donc ok il ya un
secrétaire d'état qui fait ce qu'il peut
mais je pense qu'il faut au delà de ça
renforcer ce pilotage
j'ai un peu en tête depuis le début
toute la comparaison ayant ses limites
mais un peu là ce qui fait ce qui se
fait sur le champ du handicap avec la
cns a ou autour de l'atc un peu le
principe aussi du gipn aujourd'hui ans
et on se met autour de la table on a un
gip vous avez l'état les départements
qui seront représentés au même au même
niveau les associations évidemment dont
les associations d'enfants et c'est
l'endroit où se construit un peu cette
politique où on construit les
référentiels par exemple qui peuvent
servir de référentiel commun où on
partage les bonnes expériences parce que
quand même moi je reste je le reste sera
payé par le fait que en réalité il ya
plein de choses très bien qu'ils soient
aux quatre coins du territoire il ya
plein d'innovations territoriale plein
d'innovations sociales sauf que les
autres ne sont pas au courant donc ça
doit être le lieu aussi de cet échange
de ces échanges de bonnes pratiques et
puis dans cette réforme
nationale de la gouvernance il ya aussi
tout un enjeu sur la connaissance en
protection de l'enfance on a aujourd'hui
l'observatoire national à protection
l'enfance qui fait du bon boulot mais je
pense que collectivement on peut mieux
faire et donc l'idée est de renforcer
l'observatoire national à protection de
l'enfance de lui adjoindre les services
de l'adresse qui permettra notamment de
croiser des bases de données ce qui
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui et ce qui
permettra d'avoir enfin des vrais
parcours en protection de l'enfance et
de pouvoir vraiment connaître les les
parcours des enfants notamment de réseau
les des résultats vraiments les sujets
donc là il y en a un gros enjeu avec une
vrai enjeu d'articulation entre ici
entre le national et local et comment
les données remontent du local ce qui
aujourd'hui est un parfaitement fait
et donc ça là ça va consister mais ça
c'est la conséquence au rapprochement de
quatre organismes existants que sont le
l'observatoire national de la protection
de l'enfance sa part dont le gipn
excusez moi donc le groupement d'intérêt
public enfants sont en danger
qui gère le 119 vous c'est fait vous le
savez auquel et au sein duquel et
l'observatoire là sur la protection de
l'enfance la fin l'agencé française de
l'adoption
le cnao qui aura une part un peu à part
parce qu'il a une mission un peu à part
je pense qu'ils auront des projets gars
et des réflexions à mener en commun avec
la pha notamment mais dans un premier
temps cela leur permet de s'affirmer moi
de les consolider ils sont très
demandeurs on avait eu des balades
sûrement la loi de bioéthique
et puis le cnt eux aussi dans sa
fonction
la vie indépendant sur les projets du
gouvernement et qui sera jeudi
regroupement de 4 organise pour
l'instant il est il est un peu il ya un
peu à part le secrétariat général du du
gip assurera lé enfin le gipn en
assurera le secrétariat du cnpe mais on
va cette fonction d' avis sur les
projets du gouvernement indépendant me
semble devoir être préservée dans
l'esprit je crois que qui était celui de
laurence rossignol quand ça a été quand
ça a été créé
et je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur
la gouvernance locale et j'ai demandé
aux députés de ne pas trop avancer sur
ce sujet là pour que ce soit débattue
ici je vous donne très brièvement mon
avis et mais qui n'est que le mien
l'aude et je pense que ça va s'appuyer
sur le réseau des pays existants il ne
faut pas recommencer à recréer des
choses
je pense que la notion d'observatoire
mais pas vraiment la bonne ou en tout
cas celle que moi je projette ce qu
observateur c'est un peu passif alors
que je pense que ce l'eau dpe doit
devenir le lieu actif de la
détermination un peu stratégique et de
la conduite très opérationnelle ap tic
dans de l'enfant sur le territoire
ces infos plus que sa soif aux plus
jeunes formant c'est mon opinion que ça
soit juste à une réunion annuelle où on
se partage les chiffres incomplets un
parfait de la protection d'enfants sur
le territoire mais que ça soit vraiment
le lieu de réunion où les départements
évidemment et l'état tous les services
de l'état impliqués soient là pour
vraiment piloter au plus près leur décès
en france en gt en côtes d'armor en
début de l'été sa maison parmi d'autres
et en côtes d'armor c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont une équipe qui fonctionne
d'ores et déjà voilà et tout le monde
est là et on se voit tous les deux mois
est vraiment au pilote la politique
alors et au risque d'être d'être
de vous choquer mais mais mais je
rêverais même que ça soit le dpe soit
demain coprésidée par le président du
département et par le préfet ou par en
tout cas un représentant de l'état
mais le dpe j'ai peut-être un peu loin
le seul reporter mais le dpe est
vraiment l'image ça c'est un organe du
département donc c'est pour ça que ce
n'est pas à moi de le dire ce sera à
vous éventuellement d'avancé sur ce
terrain là si vous pensez que c'est
pertinent voilà
il ya d'autres sujets qui sont ouverts
je pense comme on parle vraiment de
l'organisation des départements eux
mêmes
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont pensé c'est un
peu technique mais moi la notion de prix
de journée pour des enfants et ça ça va
toujours un peu
interrogé sur le principe sur la
sémantique je voyais sur le médico
social on est passé au ces pommes ce qui
me semble permettent d'avoir une vision
un peu stratégie de visibilité aux
gestionnaires voilà après moi je n'ai
jamais été élu local je ne sais pas
comment ça se passe si c'est bien si
c'est mieux pas mieux ce que je vois
c'est quand même qu'on a des administrés
à faire des policiers au galion le cpom
pour le médico social les prix de
journée pour le social vous avez en face
des associations qui sont souvent sur
les 200 qui ont donc allé de mal à ça me
semble pas le plus efficient possible
donc c'est peut-être quelque chose sur
lequel vous voudrez venir
il ya la question des à des papes qui
sont les associations d'anciens enfants
protégés qui sont dans le code de
l'action sociale en ce qui est très rare
je pense à parler l'unaf et les udaf je
sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de deux
associations qui sont dans le code qui
ont un vrai rôle institutionnel dans le
code je me souviens plus de la rédaction
précise enfin ils font partie du système
or on constate qu'ils sont assez
dépendant en réalité que la subvention
va lui donner valdonnez les au
département où des appels à projets va
lancer le département auquel ils vont
répondre qu'ils vont gagner ou pas et je
juge j'ai réfléchi j'ai cherché je n'ai
pas trouvé mais si on pouvait trouver
une façon mais là ça touche directement
aux finances locales donc c'est pour ça
que je suis encore très très prudent
mais si on pouvait trouver une façon de
leur donner un peu de visibilité et
l'assise financière parce qu'ils ont
quand il dit quand ils sont structurés
quand ils jouent un rôle et joue un vrai
rôle là j'étais à marseille en début de
semaine bas il joue un vrai rôle pour
accompagner notamment après la sortie du
dispositif savard ans à créer du lien et
stains voilà si on pouvais je sais pas
allouer montant forfaitaire du budget du
département très minime mais qu'ils qui
serait déjà beaucoup à 0,00 0,1 pour
cent du budget pour l'ad-pa pour
fonction du nombre d'enfants protéger
dans le département pour leur donner un
peu de jeunesse très bien mais je laisse
ouvert jeunesse ouvert la discussion
voilà et je pense enfin que l'on peut
faire des choses sur le milieu ouvert
sur tout ce qui est à l'ump faisait
beaucoup parler prévention je pense que
sur la hem hausse et pas suffisamment
movies et j'avais lancé une conférence
de consensus une deuxième sur le milieu
ouvert j'avais confié à jeune fille avec
guesdon ça ne représentent que 18% des
mesures je pense que ce n'est pas
suffisant il ya eu un amendement qui a
été déposée par isabelle santiago à
l'assemblée pour un peu asseoir et
développer la même eau je pense qu'on
peut aller plus loin et notamment
aujourd'hui aussi a probalement des
sujets sur comment faire en sorte que
ces mesures soient davantage approprié
par les différents acteurs et puis il ya
peut-être aussi un sujet de deux il ya
aussi de contrôle de contrôle aussi de
la même eau c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez juge qui donne qui prononce
pardon des décisions en milieu ouvert
des associations qui les met en oeuvre
mais si on demandait aux départements
voire même au juge si elle était
effectivement mise en oeuvre combien de
fois le travailleur social passe
effectivement par semaine ça je ne suis
pas sûr je dis ça parce que j'ai
rencontrées sur le terrain je suis pas
sûr que quiconque puisse répondre et
c'est un peu problématique quand même et
je pouvais un certain nombre de
départements qui ont exprimé le
sentiment d'être mise à l'écart puisque
les décisions sont prises par les juges
alors que les départements
accessoirement son financeur voilà mes
donc là donc je vois là je ma réflexion
n'est pas aboutie j'ai essayé qu'elle a
semblé y ait des échanges là dessus il
ya eu un premier pas de fait je pense
qu'on peut peut-être il ya vous aurez
peut-être l'occasion de voile et enfin
pour conclure vous dire que tout ce que
je vous raconte là tout ce que je fais
depuis le départ et corinne imbert qui
est là qui étaient là qui est parti pour
en témoigner sur un autre sujet qui est
celui de l'adoption tout ce que je fais
je le fais depuis le début avec les
départements avec l'association des
départements de france voilà une fois
encore je pense que l'on améliorera le
système ensemble où ce sera le statu quo
ensemble voilà et donc cesser c'est dans
cet esprit là que je suis depuis trois
ans et que je demeure aujourd'hui
voilà monsieur le rapporteur très bien
donc avant de passer au reporter nous
avons aimé laurent en parlant
vraisemblablement laurent bourgoin a
rendu ce matin rapport sur les mineurs
non accompagnés
vous avez raison je n'en ai pas parlé il
ya quelques dispositions qui porte les
mineurs non accompagnés dans le texte
gérard roujas des questions si vous lui
enverra et
et dans le cas de rapport que doit
rendre la mission sauver sur les
violences sexuelles sur mineurs dans
l'église c'est mercredi prochain que la
commission sauvé le 5 donne son rapport
je proposerai vraisemblablement que
peut-être après l'interruption
parlementaire on puisse faire un bilan
d'évaluation de ce qui aurait été je
regarde michaud munich était co
rapporteur de cette commission que je
préside est un bilan un peu de ce qui a
été fait mais peut-être lié à d'ores et
déjà dans le texte puisqu'il y avait
toute une partie qui concernait aussi
les mineurs confiés à la the par rapport
à ces violences sexuelles subies en
institution
donc je laisse la parole à bernard bonne
le rapporteur de cette ex finalement
puis tout ce que vous demandez au sénat
de ajouté au texte heureusement qu'ils
aient reculé heureusement qu retardé à
oui
très bien oui merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre de la volonté
que vous avez en tout cas d'améliorer le
système de protection de l'enfance des
enfants qui nous sont confiés j'ai
essayé d'aller rapidement avec quelques
questions sachant qu'il aura beaucoup
d'autres qui seront posées certainement
qu'il y aura beaucoup de discussions par
rapport à ce projet de loi et qui
effectivement ne pourra pas tout
aujourd'hui avec le temps imparti que
nous avons parlé de tous les sujets mais
quand même lecture du projet de loi y
ait deux constats qui s'imposent le
premier est que ce texte qui est assez
disparate se vendent souvent ajusté ou à
répéter les principes ou des dispositifs
qui existent déjà ce dont vous allez
parler tout à leur parrainage qui ruine
de confiance et c'est le second constat
est qu'il ne tire pas les conséquences
du défaut d'application des dernières
lois de 2007 et de 2016 dont vous avez
parlé le projet pour l'enfant est trop
peu appliquées les médecins référents en
protection de l'enfance manque encore de
nombreux départements et l'objectif fixé
en 2007 de déjudiciariser la protection
de l'enfance en privilégiant les mesures
administratives plutôt que judiciaire
est très loin d'être atteint au total en
perçoit assez mal à lignes fixées par ce
texte et les moyens engagés pour
améliorer réellement l'existant quels
objectifs vous fixez vous avec ce projet
de loi
la deuxième question le texte propose un
certain nombre de mesures nouvelles qui
vont dans le bon sens mais qui auront un
coût important pour les départements
alors vous avez dit qu'il y aurait une
compensation mais entre la limitation de
l'hébergement à l'hôtel l'accompagnement
des jeunes majeurs jusqu'à 21 ans la
revalorisation des rémunérations des
assistants familiaux
quel sera le coût pour les départements
qui n'ont aujourd'hui plus d'autonomie
financière et qui sont un peu exemple à
tous points de vue quels sont les
engagements du gouvernement
immédiat et pérenne surtout pérenne pour
justement aider financièrement les
départements et la mise en oeuvre de ces
diverses mesures concernant la
gouvernance je vais pas en parler
beaucoup parce que on attendait au dpe
au niveau de l'assemblée nationale ils
ont mis plus comme eu un rôle
d'animation vous parler maintenant d'une
co construction des projets
départementaux on en est pas du tout là
donc je crois qu'on en parlera un peu
après s'agissant des assistants
familiaux la démographie de la
profession est déclinante et sans un
regain de recrutement les départements
vont bientôt connaître de grosses
difficultés pour confier un enfant dans
un accueil familial le projet de loi
prévoit certaines mesures vise à
revaloriser les rémunérations des
assistants familiaux
à elles seules ces dispositions
financières ne seront pas suffisantes
pour encourager les locations quelles
autres mesures prévoyez-vous pour
renforcer l'attractivité de la
profession et ne peut-on pas envisager
une campagne de communication nationale
pour revaloriser le métier d'assistant
familial
et puis les services de médecine
scolaire autant que ceux de la pmi sont
d une situation préoccupante dans bon
nombre de départements on a parlé
beaucoup de prévention je crois que la
prévention est essentielle mais le suivi
médical des enfants n'est que très peu
abordée dans ce projet de loi qui se
limite à quelques dispositions sur la
pmi s'en octroyer de moyens
supplémentaires au département pour leur
permettre vraiment d'exercer leurs
compétences et notamment faire de la
prévention
comment les relations entre les services
de médecine scolaire et ceux de la pmi
pourrait être améliorée afin que des
enfants est un parcours médical
coordonnées
quel alors dans la prévention je pense
aussi qu'il y aura une action très forte
auprès des familles avec le la volonté
de maintien au moins du lien avec les
familles beaucoup plus fortement qu'on a
aujourd'hui et donc ça serait à mes
questions et puis une dernière remarque
qui n'est pas une question
on a été un peu surpris quand même de
voir que le projet de loi sur la
protection animale et est priorisé par
rapport aux à la loi sur la protection
de l'enfance il faudra nous expliquer
pourquoi
merci monsieur le ministre en tout cas
merci à narbonne on va prendre également
encore deux autres collègues et il y
aura ensuite une salve de trois
questions michel meunier ensuite laurent
burton merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre toutes ces
questions posées par notre rapporteur
auraient pu être les miennes et je ne
ferai évidemment pas moi j'apprécie la
manière dont vous preniez ce sujet
depuis votre arrivée à la fois dans sa
globalité et sa complexité donc je les
trois piliers que vous avez développées
et sont bien là et ils sont à à prendre
en compte vous dites monsieur le
ministre qu'il noie ne fait pas tout et
vous avez raison parce que c'est quelque
part un peu consternant
d'entendre au fur et à mesure de nos
éditions audition avec bernard bonne et
d'autres collègues bon nombre de
dispositions contenues dans la loi de
2016 qui ne sont pas appliquées et ce
matin encore on en parlait à propos du
rapport sur les mineurs non accompagnés
seulement 20% des départements ont ni en
place
l'entretien préalable à 15 ans 16 ans
pour préparer la sortie de ces jeunes en
protection de l'enfance donc voilà donc
d'autres exemples pourraient aussi être
pris notamment sur le projet personnel
de l'enfant qui lui est quand même
l'ossature de tout ce qui devait être
fait pour lui dans sa protection une
seule question qui concerne à la fois
lit mineur et l'opportunité de ce texte
qui ne nous arrive pas encore comme
prévu au mois d'octobre le 1er octobre
la vendredi va s'arrêter la mesure pour
les sorties sèches de la za c'était une
mesure qui avait été décidé lors des
premières mesures sur la crise sanitaire
et c'est heureux pour éviter donc ses
sorties sans solution ça s'arrête au 1er
octobre alors avant le vote de votre loi
monsieur le ministre qu'est ce que vous
pensez mettre en place effectivement
pour qu'on ne soit pas à nouveau avec
cette menace pour les jeunes pris en
charge et qui auront 18 ans voilà je
m'arrêterai là et beaucoup d'autres
questions il s'arrête là merci non oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre avec mes collègues iacovelli
leroy et bourgi nous allons présenter
donc ce matin
comme le disait madame la présidente de
la commission et la commission des lois
les conclusions d'une mission
d'information sur les mineurs non
accompagnés
la question est mais n'a fait l'objet de
quelques dispositions dans le projet de
loi qui ne sont pas suffisantes à notre
avis dans notre rapport nous
recommandant notamment le transfert à
l'état de la compétence d'évaluation et
de mise à l'abri des personnes se
présentant comme et ménard qui
représente nous semble-t-il une charge
indue pour les départements en outre
l'exercice par l'état de cette
compétence permettrait d'harmoniser les
pratiques d'évaluation entre les
territoires et de mieux coordonner les
différents services de l'état qui de
fait ils concourent déjà à savoir les
préfectures la police aux frontières
la direction de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse mais aussi les parquet et
les juges des enfants dès lors quelle
est votre position sur un tel transfert
de compétences deuxième balle la
contribution du réceptionneur de l'état
au surcroît de dépenses de l'aide
sociale a en face imputable au mnr
s'effondre en quelques années passant de
96 millions d'euros en 2018 à 1,7
million d'euros en 2021 alors même que
l'effectif de m et n'a pris en charge
est resté élevé ne vous paraît-il pas
possible de pérenniser de la loi cette
contribution est de revoir son mode de
calcul de telle sorte qu'ils prennent en
compte les effectifs plutôt que les flux
ainsi que la part de m et n'a pas remis
les enfants pris en charge au titre de
la zone merci beaucoup
parce que le ministre sur laisse
répondre à ces trois premiers comme sa
mère beaucoup me présente devant un
certain nombre de questions
structurantes profonde
je vais essayer de répondre de façon de
façon synthétique hier monsieur le
rapporteur il
il est clair que enfin je vais pas
revenir sur chacun des aspects de votre
toute première question
je pense une fois encore qu'il y à un
certain nombre de dispositions de ce
texte
qui sont qui ont toute leur utilité leur
nécessité
et que la réaffirmation dans la loi la
mise en valeur au cours de nos débats
d'un certain nombre de dispositions de
convictions fortes qui sont les nôtres
que ce soit sur le la question des
séparations des fratries par exemple que
vous avez cité la question du tiers
digne de confiance
ont toute leur place dans ce texte et
tout cela n'est pas superfétatoire comme
le monde y
est ça renvoie je l'admets à vos propos
de michel meunier sur la question de
l'application de la loi ce que vous
citez la loire de 2016 mais on pourrait
sauter même la loi de 2007 certes quand
je suis arrivé
je suis arrivé il y avait 50 peut-être
60 départements qui avaient mis en place
leur au dpe est encore certain nombre
d'entre eux venaient de le faire en 2007
c'était il ya quatorze ans
donc hélas aujourd'hui on est à 80 ou 85
alors bon je moi je
je verse et aussi aux
ja vous serez d'accord avec moi au
département là aussi de d'appliquer la
loi et d'être au rendez vous un de leurs
compétences quand même enfin je viens
d'un côté on peut pas revendiquer une
compétence et la raison puisqu'elle a
été a été centré et de l'autre côté ne
pas être au rendez-vous de l'exercice de
cette compétence et l'eau dpe par
exemple mais le projet pour l'enfant
plus encore parce qu'il concerne encore
plus directement l'enfant et puis c'est
un vrai changement un peu de paradigme
quand même enfin monsieur bonne parlait
de du maintien maintien plus plus accrue
des liens avec la famille
le projet de loi n'a pas vocation à
revenir là dessus moi je pense que l'
équilibre qui a été trouvé par la loi
2016 sur le maintien des liens
d'attachement enfin là c'était et
notamment au travers du justement du
projet pour l'enfant est le bon et donc
on aurait ouvre pas ceux des bagues dont
vous savez qu'il est très idéologique et
qu'il est et c'est assez symptomatique
justement parfois de la façon dont la
loi se percutent l'exercice
des pratiques professionnelles et la
formation qu'ont pu recevoir un certain
nombre de travailleurs sociaux
moi j'ai bon espoir
on pourrait peut-être naïf mais je
voulais dit moi je pense que des
dysfonctionnements qu'on a pu constater
on constate encore dans l'aide sociale
enfance et parfois liés à des
comportements individuels et qu'il faut
dénoncer sanctionné et mettre en place
les mécanismes d'alerté 2 et de contrôle
ils sont parfois liés à des départements
qui n'exerce pas la compétence comme ils
sont censés exercer
et ils sont aussi liés ces
dysfonctionnements parfois au fait que
l'état n'était pas suffisamment investi
dans cette compétence est pas pour
reprendre la main mettre sa tutelle ou
quoi que ce soit mais
parce qu'une fois encore les questions
de scolarité les questions de santé que
vous avez évoqué
le fait que 80% effectivement des
décisions la presse en france aux
éditions judiciaire donc c'est bien là
aussi l'état et la rega lien
voilà n'était pas allé les services de
l'état n'était pas suffisamment investi
et donc moi je gens
je pense que ce réinvestissement
j'appelle de mes voeux et que le texte
traduit et même des choses hors texte
l'intérieur de l'appartement d'éclairage
supplémentaire va
permettre que
les préfets en tout cas les services de
la préfecture soit davantage investi sur
7 cette compétence et nous allons
notamment ça sera c'est pas du domaine
de la loi c'est le même temps
réglementaire nous allons désigner au
sein des préfectures un référent
personne responsable pour l'état dans
les territoires sur la protection de
l'enfance voilà pour qu'il y ait d'une
part
les acteurs nous le demande que ce soit
les départements parfois ou les
associations on ne sait pas à qui
s'adresser et puis parce que on a failli
zi l'état est en réalité plusieurs
services de l'état qui sont qui sont
concernés qui parfois on le sait aussi
on peut se le dire ne communique pas
totalement complètement entre entre le
préfet qui lui
restait sur le fait qu' il ya trente ans
on avait décentralisé la compétence et
que donc c'était le département est pas
lui et puis là beaucoup de choses à
faire
le responsable d'académie la rs qui
connaît mal on peut se le dire par le
sait pourquoi qui connaît mal l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et le social et donc
avoir quelqu'un qui est un peu animaux
si cette équipe de l'état est en
meilleure coordination et coopération
avec le département 1 c'est une
nécessité et j'ai envie de croire que ça
permettra aussi de faire en sorte que le
respect des dispositions votées par les
députés les sénateurs seront mieux
appliquées par les premiers concernés
[Musique]
vous m'avez demandé monsieur le
rapporteur
sur les assistants familiaux merci
madame la présidente donc j'ai commencé
à apporter quelques éléments de réponse
vous dire d'une part tout ça est le
fruit de discussions que nous avons avec
les associations et les les syndicats et
les employeurs publics comme privés que
donc oui tous les départements sont
confrontés à cette pyramide
démographique défavorable
ce métier est mal connus et méconnus je
pense par ailleurs ce métier est
difficile et il a changé les assistantes
familiales celles qui ont quelques
années déjà elle nous le disent nous
disent les enfants ne sont plus les
mêmes
et c'est parce qu'on le sait c'est
beaucoup lié à les troubles comportement
des troubles psys qui sont en croissance
chez dans notre jeunesse depuis un
certain nombre d'années
notamment chez les enfants delay tient
en france parce que les psycho trauma
liés notamment à des violences physiques
ou sexuelles ne sont pas bien repéré ne
sont pas bien accompagné qui a dû
sûrement dit cap qui secret et que ces
enfants là sont mal prises en charge par
notre système se retrouvent dans des
foyers souvent ils se mettent en danger
ils mettent en rang et font exploser le
groupe qui met en danger les
travailleurs sociaux les retrouve
souvent chez les assistantes familiales
un peu en dernier recours et et elles se
sentent très seuls face à cela parce que
ce n'est pas leur compétence et ça ne le
sera jamais fin juin ce n'est pas qu'une
question pas une question de formation
en fait c'est juste n'est pas leur
métier leurs compétences que de prendre
en charge sur ce volet soins epci les
enfants donc ce qui me permet de dire
que quand je dis que l'état doit être au
rendez vous de ses compétences ça me
permet de dire qu'il ya un gros boulot
de fait sur la pédopsychiatrie aussi
alors il ya des annonces hier vous
l'avez lu par le président de la
république a eu déjà des choses qui ont
été faites je t'ai annoncé par agnès
buzyn de la feuille de route de santé
mentale monsieur savary mais enfin vous
voyez vous le savez ça fait 20 ans juste
qu'on abandonne la tournée avant des
psychiatres il fait aussi entrer dans ce
pays donc voila mais effectivement
1 on réessaie de répondre à l'urgence
avec en créant des postes d'assistant
chef de clinique en créant des équipes
mobiles en pédopsychiatrie financée
notamment par
par le via la contractualisation je
pense notamment aux pyrénées-orientales
si je dis pas de bêtises
qui met en place une équipe et
psychiatrie il ya aussi dans l'allier il
ya aussi voilà ou avec des équipes
mobiles qui interviennent dans les
foyers ou auprès des assistantes
familiales qui se sent très seul face à
ses juges l'un et puis oui on recrée des
postes en cmp parce qu'il ya des files
d'attentes pas possible enfin bon voilà
et puis et puis on essaie de préparer
l'avenir
donc
prime de démographie les métiers de plus
en de plus en plus dur et puis une
question autour du statut et de la
rémunération donc rémunération dans le
texte smic dès le premier enfant alors
oui une surcharge pour les départements
près je pense qu'on peut se dire que
c'est pas totalement scandaleux qu'une
assistante familiale qui besoin de
quatre sets et qui maintenant bah c'est
pas ça mais c'est un peu quand même ça
c'est un peu quand même ça
oui alors ça crée un financement mais
julien que ce dont on peut se dire alors
déjà déjà d'une part déjà certains
beaucoup de départements le font déjà en
réalité et est je pense une majorité
j'ai pas de chiffres précis et beaucoup
d'états ont le font déjà je trouve que
c'est bien de mettre dans la loi pour
ceux qui ne le font pas que dès le
premier agrément il faut quand même le
smic ça ça participe ce n'est pas
suffisant vous êtes totalement raison à
l'attractivité du métier ça me semble
pas totalement indigne dans ce qu'ils ne
font pas les assistantes maternelles
familiale pardon qui n'ont qu'un
agrément aucun enfant c'est aussi loin
d'être très très loin d'être la majorité
des essential dans le département donc
le surcoût en réalité il est assez
marginal s'il faut prévoir des
mécanismes de compensation cds chose sur
lequel on peut donc je suis je peux je
peux être ouverts parce que je pense que
les sommes ne sont sont très très loin
d'être d'être phénoménal mais pour les
personnes et pour l'attractivité du
métier c'est important la même façon
pour le maintien du salaire pendant
quatre mois sur pendant la période de
suspension là aussi fort heureusement il
n'y a pas des centaines chaque année de
deux procédures dans les départements
etc et puis là aussi à des départements
et notamment les bouches-du-rhône où
j'étais lundi qui a déjà qui a déjà mis
en place ce système a d'ailleurs on
s'est beaucoup inspiré de choses déjà
existantes
donc il ya ça et puis elle les à côtés
je vous en ai parlé aux réformes de
l'ingénierie du diplôme niveau 5a niveau
4 les histoires de formation
le handicap bon ce qu'on fait par
ailleurs cp2 sur la pédopsychiatrie et
puis une campagne nationale oui pourquoi
mais j'ai envie de vous dire enfin
peut-être qu'un de vous m'interrogera là
dessus mais s'il devait y avoir une
campagne nationale de communication je
pense qu'il faudrait le faire même sur
l'ensemble du travail social et des
travailleurs sociaux
pour lesquels on a des problèmes de
recrutement
et j'en parlais encore hier soir j'étais
encore interpellé là dessus oui à la
prime de valorisation de ce métier sans
fins de reconnaissance financière
peut-être mais aussi symbolique de ce
métier là et de mes connaissances
globales de ces métiers là je pense de
la part de la population sont fait une
idée image un peu un peu datés je pense
par rapport à la réalité du métier
aujourd'hui donc donc oui voire même au
delà pour répondre à votre question
d'autres
points sur la médecine scolaire donc je
ne vais pas réouvrir les débats que vous
avez eue je crois à sauf erreur au
moment du projet de loi cadre des
puisqu'il y avait des demandes de la
part d'un certain nombre de départements
peut être relayée ici sur une idée de
décentralisation de la médecine scolaire
pour l'adjoindre enfin la créer un
continuum qui est pas inintéressant sur
le sur le fond entre pmi et médecine
scolaire c'est une voix qui n'a pas été
retenue par le gouvernement à ce stade
sauf sauf erreur
la médecine ce que je pense pour être
bref va et sans réponse et en actions
mais moi je pense qu'on a un sujet sur
le parcours de santé des enfants et
qu'il faut qu'on arrête de rentrer dans
ce sujet là par la question du statut
des uns et des autres faut qu'on parle
de l'enfant on se doit de 0 à 11 ou de 0
à 16 quel et quel doit être le parcours
de santé des enfants mais aujourd'hui 20
visite médicale parce que les 20 de
londres tout le monde ne le fait pas je
pense que personne n'est capable de
savoir qu'il fait vraiment quoi et par
ailleurs dans vos territoires où ça être
un cas des situations quand même de
pénurie de médecins de pmi de médecins
scolaires il n'a plus puissant en france
en
est donc si on a parlé des généralistes
et des spécialistes et que ce n'est pas
que dans les territoires ruraux bon donc
moi je pense que il faut qu'on se pose
la question de parcours de soins je ne
suis pas sûr j'aurai le temps de la
mener à terme d'ici les prochains mois
mais je pense que le sujet commence à y
réfléchir et apporter quelques réponses
mais je pense qu'il ya un sujet en soi
qu'il faut aborder et sans rentrer par
les statuts la question des statuts de a
qui y est rattachée les médecins de
l'aide de la médecine scolaire si tenté
que ça nous avait évolué ça doit être la
conséquence d'une réflexion qu'on a et
deux parcours de soin qu'on va qu'on va
mettre en place et je pense très
sincèrement que ça sera pas le même de
territoire à territoire parce que les
situations théâtrales sont très très
différentes et autant j'étais assez
sceptique sur le bon fonctionnement des
dynamiques territoriales que l'on
suscitait quand je vois qu'en fonction
de laisser pts quand je vois comment
fonctionne les projets territoriaux de
santé mentale etc j'ai l'impression que
ces dynamiques sont quand même assez
active fonctionne assez bien les acteurs
s'investissent et concret des vrais
parcours de santé pour les patients en
partant de voilà donc bon voilà c'est
des bandes puisque je jette comme ça
mais mais voilà
et madame
madame meunier way sur les sorties
effectivement au regard de la situation
économique
l'accueil sanitaire économie pendant
l'état d'urgence j'ai demandé à son
interdisent le tout sortis du dispositif
d aide sociale en france parce que pour
trouver un stage pour trouver un boulot
et sert à projeter ou un en arrière
c'était pas ça encore et encore moins
simple pour ces enfants que pour le club
pour les autres donc on a fait ça on a
compensé à 50 millions d'euros la
première fois et puis quand on l'a
reconduit à la demande des sénateurs je
me souviens des débats on je me suis
pris l'engagement au bon
qu'il y aurait une compensation à l'euro
sur présentation des frais engagés par
les départements parce qu'il me semble
de bonne bonne gouvernance
effectivement ce dispositif arrive à
terme avant avec la fin de l'état l'état
d'urgence là dessus de trois éléments
d'une part enfin ne pas laisser ce n'est
pas votre cas mais ne pas laisser
prospérer l'idée quelque peu insultant
de je trouve
que là depuis un an et demi
les
départements les professionnels de la
mission locale des missions locales
les responsables en sont servis des
départements se sont tournés les pouces
en attendant le 30 septembre pour
appuyer sur le bouton et sortir tout le
monde enfin je suis désolé j'en parlais
on en parlait encore ont terminé avec la
seine-saint-denis j'analyse enfin ils
ont travaillé à la sortie et à la fin de
ce dispositif
deuxième élément de contexte la
situation économique a changé faut s'en
réjouir savait pas dire que ça résout la
situation et qu'on doit tout faire
reposer sur la situation économique mais
quand même vous le savez il ya un
certain nombre de boulot donc pourvu et
quand le premier ministre annonce 900
millions d'euros d'ici la fin de l'année
sur la formation professionnelle ça
profite à tous nos jeunes et au delà
dont les jeunes de l'aide sociale en
france aussi et ce d'autant plus qu'on a
mobilisé avec elisabeth bornes les
missions locales notamment sur ce public
qui pendant longtemps et vous l'avez
dénoncer et vous y avez remédier qui
étaient souvent des dans l'angle mort de
la république est aujourd'hui par les
acteurs de l'emploi ils sont identifiés
comme un public prioritaire
voilà et puis troisième en et vous avez
posé la question sous le bon angle
effectivement je l'édile le projet de
loi va permettre d'avoir normalement de
permettre à chaque jeune d'avoir une
solution en sortie mais d'ici laquelle
le tuilage excusez-moi l'expression mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle
s'assurer qu'il ya pas de 10,6 à
l'adoption du projet de loi et je vais
écrire au département dans ce sens pour
que les choses soient bien claires mais
s'il y a des jeunes qui devrait ne pas
trouver de solution à travers la
garantie jeunes ou de dispositifs
d'insertion professionnelle etc eh bien
je demande au département de continuer à
poursuivre la prise en charge des
enfants en fonction de ce qui leur
convient et l'état compensera voilà
jusqu'à l'adoption du projet de loi qui
lui la mettra en place un peu le système
de droit commun donc voilà ce qu'on a ce
qu on a envisagé oui mais ben jeu c'est
pour ça que je me verrais de le dire
brigitte de bureaux vignon a été
interpellé en fin à une question
hier c'est elle qui était à l'assemblée
moi j'étais chez tes ailleurs et elle a
répondu en ce sens et dont je le mets je
le redis je le redis
et enfin monsieur monsieur le sénateur
alors le alors le coeur du projet de loi
en question ne porte pas sur les mineurs
non accompagnés mais mais néanmoins si
quand même
puisque moi je suis évidemment un ardent
défenseur et voir promoteurs de
l'unicité de la protection de l'enfance
donc tout ce qu'on fait dans son associé
dans ce projet de loi concerne tous les
enfants de la protection de l'enfance et
les mineurs non accompagnés sont
mineures avant d'être non accompagnés
enfin moi là dessus je suis ce clair
c'est normal enfin c'est comme ça
deux éléments
dont enfin deuxièmement de questions sur
la question de l'évaluation de la mise à
l'abri bon d'une part il ya eu un boulot
pour le mot vous avez parlé le
d'homogénéisation de l'évaluation est
une matière compliquée et c'est un sujet
compliqué mais il ya eu un travail
d'homogénéisation avec un guide
d'évaluation qui a été élaboré par la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale et qui a été transmis alors son
département pour qui est justement une
homogénéité de l'évaluation
fait qu'on tende vers selon
moi je une fois encore je
je suis favorable à l'unicité de la
protection de l'enfance donc pour moi
les mineurs partir du moment où ils sont
mineurs
et qui est une présomption de minorités
c'est pour ça qu'on les met à l'abri
avant que l'évaluation soit rendu
doit rester dans le cas de la protection
de l'enfance alors je n'ai pas lu votre
rapport parce que sauf erreur il n'est
pas encore public
donc un accord
alors
je donc je ne sais qu'une fois que vous
dites transfert à l'état
quand bien même on s'enfonce accorderait
sur le principe je ne sais pas si vous
dites à qui vous
transférerez riez cela parce qu'une fois
encore l'état je lirai le rapport donc
mais est-ce que effectivement est-ce que
c'est aux miss à l'intérieur est ce que
c'est à nous est ce que c'est juste
vraiment de solidarité est ce que c'est
à la justice
voilà mes
mais à ce stade je suis moi pas
favorable à ce qu'il y ait un transfert
enfin ces choses qui est en tout cas ce
faut en discuter dans les détails
sur la contribution alors je n'ai je pas
bon mais on les a renié ce que je n'ai
pas les chiffres en tête écoutez il ya
le l'accord financier
est le fruit
d'un accord entre le gouvernement et une
association qui s'appelle l'association
des départements de france
c'est l'accord financier tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui pour pour d'une part
sur la phase d'évaluation mise à l'abri
donc les 500 euros dont 100 euros
pour le bilan de santé et pas toujours
fait
et puis ensuite montant forfaitaire par
jour pour
pendant 24 jours décomposée en deux
périodes pour compenser la mise à l'abri
et pour essayer de faire en sorte que
les délais aussi on peut se le dire
c'était qu'on pose sur 24 jours pour
faire en sorte que les délais
d'évaluation se réduisent et puis
ensuite la part forfaitaire
effectivement sur le nombre de mineurs
supplémentaires par rapport à elles
moins un sur un contingent de 75% de
mémoire
c'est le fruit sauf erreur et c'était
avant que j'arrive d'un accord entre le
gouvernement et l'association des
départements de france c'est pas le
gouvernement qui tout seul à des ses
dessins
et alors j'ai pas noté les chiffres que
vous que vous évoquez mais sur les homos
on me dit et c'est dans la loi de
finances que pour l'évaluation et la
mise à l'abri on est passé de 65
millions en 2019 70 millions en 2020 et
98 millions en 2021
et en tout avec la contribution
exceptionnelle dont vous faisiez aucune
avance c 130 millions pour l'année 2019
voilà alors effectivement géant rejet en
tendu les départements disant que
c'était beaucoup plus que cela mais une
fois encore cet accord face et
dédommagements résultat résulte d'un
accord que nous avons peut-être qui a
été fait entre entre le gouvernement et
l'association des départements de france
voilà donc pour cette audition d'adrien
taquet le secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'enfance et des familles était
auditionné cet après-midi par la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'ordre du jour la protection de
l'enfance un texte a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale au mois de juillet
et ce texte devrait être examiné par les
sénateurs dans les prochaines semaines
on y reviendra bien évidemment sur
public sénat reste avec nous la
formation politique et parlementaire
continue sur notre antenne